insidious chapter three is not directed
by James Wan it's actually directed by
his longtime writing partner Leigh
Whannell who's been with him all the way
back to the first Saw movie and this
film is a prequel from the last two
we've already seen this film tells the
story of a young girl who's recently
lost her mother her father's played by
Dermot Mulroney and he's having a hard
time balancing a job as well as two kids
oh yeah and there also seems to be a man
who lives in the vents who can't breathe
that's horrible
I'm actually looking at the vent on my
ceiling right now hmm okay I really
enjoyed the first insidious movie I
thought it was very surprising
it took me off-guard in almost every way
it was one of the scariest pg-13 movies
I had ever seen you know what I enjoyed
the second one as well not as much as
the first one but I did think both of
these are considerably better directed
horror films than most horror films
released especially since James Wan
released insidious - and the conjuring
in the same year to be completely honest
I wasn't really that excited to see this
movie for one James wants not directing
it and it's the third film and generally
a horror films get worse as they go on
especially in franchises like this that
are made for cheap that actually make a
lot of money surprisingly I actually
thought this was better than - not quite
as good as one but still a really good
horror movie it's actually very well
directed like that's one of the biggest
surprises is actually Leigh Whannell did
a fantastic job with directing this
movie there's a lot of great uses of
suspense and tension building and if you
guys saw the video I did the problem
with horror movies today one of the
biggest things I talked about was the
rampant jump scares that are just
filling our screens in the horror films
nowadays like a friend walks up and
touches his friend's shoulder or a cat
jumps out of a dumpster or just stupid
things like that one of the things I
praised in that video though was that
insidious as a movie does use jump
scares but they're never false scares
there's always something you're actually
supposed to be terrified of that's there
and oh my gosh that's terrifying so yeah
that's a fair use of jump scares and
gratefully insidious three continues
that string of fair uses of jump scares
because there's plenty in this movie but
you're not going to see a bird fly at
someone's face or someone turn around oh
my god it's just my dad like it's always
some creepy ass
thing that's there that's meant to scare
you and that's one of the reasons why I
was actually continually startled and
most of the time on the edge also really
impressive in this movie is the acting
lin shaye who plays elise this psychic
my god
that's one of the best performances from
an actress I've seen so far this year
she was really good like it's really
easy to see a movie like this and just
be like okay it's the third and the
franchise of horror movies who cares
turn myself off but Dermot Mulroney as
the father he was great and the daughter
did a really excellent job as well all
the acting in the movie is actually
really strong which lends to the
suspense because they're taking it
seriously you know it's not like a wink
at the camera type deal they're taking
this super over-the-top haunted house
movie seriously and I like the main
creature in the movie as well there are
some truly creepy sequences throughout
the film I do have a problem with that
thing though because they don't really
explore its origin enough I wanted to
know more about like what is that thing
why is it there why is it attached to
this family what's the reasoning behind
this and since they don't explore that
there isn't really that connection there
that you want it's just a creepy thing
that is creepy and it works in that way
but I was just wanting more explanation
around the halfway point in the movie it
did lose some of that suspense it was
chugging along at a pretty good rate and
then it kind of dropped off for a while
but it picked back up again towards the
third act that middle portion was just a
bit repetitive and it kind of went on
for a little bit too long but as someone
who admires horror filmmaking and does
like to examine the art of building
suspense I got to give major props to
Leigh Whannell for taking the reigns
over in this franchise and I think
making a better movie than the last one
let me just put it this way in cities
chapter three is a much better movie
than any third film in a horror
franchise has the right to be and that's
my best way to describe this movie it is
much better than it could have been it
has really good directing it has great
performances and there are genuine
scares throughout this movie I didn't
like they didn't explore the origin of
the creature enough and I didn't like
how it kind of dropped off for a while
in the middle but for the most part I
had a lot of fun with this movie and
even though I liked it more than two I'm
going to give it the same grade I gave
that film insidious chapter 3 gets Abbey
I think if you're a fan of horror films
and you like the first two films you'll
probably find things to enjoy with this
movie so check it out if you want to
also look forward to my review of Star
Wars Episode two attack of the clones in
my continuing series of Star Wars
reviews that's going to be coming to you
next week and this weekend I also have
reviews for spy and the new Studio
Ghibli film and hopefully not the last
but possibly when Marnie was there those
reviews are coming to you very soon
thank you so much as always for watching
guys I really honestly appreciate it
very much
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes